oh hey what's going on everybody from
first we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot one it's the show of hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Padma Lakshmi you
know her from Top Chef Thursdays on
Bravo and you can pick up her new book
The Encyclopedia of spices and herbs
which is available now Padma welcome to
the show thank you I'm excited to eat
these wings I always ask people how they
are with hot food but with you and kind
of a lifestyle right it is I mean I
don't go for extremely hot like you know
Carolina Reaper or the Trinidad scorpion
those are probably the hottest peppers
in the world that we know waterliner how
do you really like the dumbest thing you
can do yeah it's I literally licked my
pinky and took a tiny taste of the
powdered version and I gotta tell you I
was worried for myself and I had to
protect my digestive tract because the
only person who eats every single thing
made on Top Chef that much okay you
ready to try this one out sure
[Music]
this first one is sriracha you know
about sriracha Josh there's no big deal
no big deal so I really only have like
two goals with this show and one of them
I've already accomplished I wanted a
sandwich named after me and thanks to
Arnold's Bar and Grill in Cincinnati I
have the Sean Evans my C cubed sandwich
the next thing on that list is I want to
be in the New York Times Sunday routine
feature section and you had a great one
in 2009 when you introduced the concept
of the bed picnic yes for the
unenlightened can you explain what a bed
picnic I can it's basically when you get
up in the morning you make your bed you
have a shower you put on a pair of crisp
pajamas or whatever you like and then
you make a bunch of different sandwiches
and you cut them nicely and you pretty
much create a platter of sandwiches and
you make a huge pot of tea and maybe
even doing a marathon of some show you
like or whatever now I think a lot of
people do that on Sundays but they don't
have the dignity with it you know I
think a lot of people are just in their
sweats with their laptops open just
eating on their bed you actually think
of it as the activity so you feel no
guilt or shame it's not like oh I was
such a you know schlub today and I just
stayed hungry said no I'm having a bad
picnic that's about three now I'm fine
recently we had Tom Colicchio on the
show and we did a Top Chef rapid fire
with him so I think it's only fair to
the fans I would go a Padma Edition as
well guest judge what the worst table
manners Oh
who do I start this guy Sam oh damn
Nazarian who is a restaurateur and not
an actual chef in the Napa finale had
bad manners I'll leave it at that
favorite host City New Orleans for
Charleston I have to say I did not know
what to expect
I've never been to Towson and in this
season were there I said six weeks there
it is awesome is there a celebrity host
that you're dying to have on the show
but because of scheduling or whatever
you haven't been able to make it work
but your
I am um Alice Waters Alice water yeah
I'd love to get her on the show I would
have left an appalled Bocuse on the show
or if she were still alive I would love
to Julia Child and you know you and Tom
have been attached at the hip not for so
long know what Tom Colicchio's most
annoying habit now I don't care I'm used
to it gives you it's like my TV husband
is right right next time for ten years
but like he has a tendency to show every
single thing he's thinking on his face
especially if he doesn't have to hide
his feelings I can't fake it no for a
while no matter what I would say he was
just rolled his eyes and now I have a
six year old at home who does the same
thing so I know how to deal with her
dealing with Tom for a long time I love
this company
oh you're psycho I did to a million ml
you Canseco guy over here I got oh you
could suck Oh basketball shorts they're
oftentimes on the scene red carpets lots
of famous friends but the one that we're
interested in is Hugh worldstar ah it
seems like you guys go all the way back
can you tell me how you guys met and
what your relationship is like you sure
Lee and I nobody calls him leaks at me
and his mother but we met on the floor
of Madison Square Garden at a Knicks
game and he was sitting there and I came
up and I sat down and he goes you look
like that girl on my favorite cooking
show I have news for you I am that girl
favorite shop we were just drinking
buddies he's like my sports companion
yes he is out there if you've ever
watched a WorldStarHipHop you know I'm
not on it that often and so I always say
to him when are you going to feature me
I'd be like I don't know about that
this one is between Majesty there's
coffee in this one this one's
interesting this is child's play this is
no big deal yet yet do you tell me about
glitter will you remember but I knew
you're gonna ask me about glitter oh man
I get asked about whitter more than my
Kerrigan that's a better not theory yeah
it might be true I was really excited to
do glitter because there's my first huge
me and at the time it was a really big
deal I had to tell you the best thing
about glitter is standing next to my
Carrie while she sings acapella she's a
freak of nature it's the same way I felt
when I saw Michael Jordan these people
have these Olympics talents my role as
usual that everyone will say was
supposed to be much bigger but most of
it wound up on the cutting room floor
so if you want to see me on glitter the
good news is that you only have to watch
the first half an hour this one is the
hot one soft your vision here show this
is my humble house our Rafa I know the
nature we did we didn't make it like you
make it I know that you make your own
hot sauce you have the tub and
everything taste it yeah yeah yeah
definitely
pop the top pop the top Padma kind of
stick my finger in whatever works for
you
[Music]
love it
[Music]
what's fruity but in a different more
fermented way definitely good can I keep
this home in my purse take that we got
another one for you oh cool okay all
right the nominees whatever you want
whatever you want ever written not in my
bag I'm talking about hot sauces we're
going to talking about it before the
show but it is kind of a complicated
process to do right I don't think a lot
of people understand that you know like
sometimes on the novelty hot sauce you
just want to send that that heat through
the roof and they care about taste and
that's fine and that's why these that
they can make right that's a gimmick but
like if you want to make like a real
actual sauce yeah you have to balance it
and that's not so easy to do you
definitely have to balance it I think
that any good hot sauce should have a
little bit of sweet a little bit of tart
and it's also be salty not only have
hotness - mm-hmm like I like the
pineapple in yours did you say you were
such fun yeah mine has pineapple now
this one's interesting okay this next
part of the show is called explain that
Graham and what we do is we do a deep
dive on our guests Instagram we pull in
treasures that just need more context Oh
God I'll show you the picture and then
you tell me the broader story oh good
all right laptop please this one's kind
of a two-parter
so a guy can this selfie with Chris Rock
yeah and then this stage which is crazy
Evans East Chris Rock Dave Chappelle
John Mayer can you tell me what this
night was all about I was actually with
Aziz that night I was out with disease
that night Aziz and I come from the same
ethnicity in India with both feet camels
and then Chris and I have been friends
for over 20 years you know I love comedy
and I'm really like you know a dirty
black man chat Indian Barbie doll body
this one's great sometimes you just got
a sometimes you just got a remind them
Pat but sometimes you just got to remind
of them I write I know I get you guys
funny I get some flack for putting sexy
pictures up of myself but honestly like
I work my ass
in the gym I have to do after eating all
that food on Top Chef so that was
actually shop on my niece she's a grad
student and she's always pushing me to
do sexier pictures and she's trying to
help me with my Instagram game and
sometimes I worship centers it isn't I
really like this working chef come on
Shaq yeah you picked some good juicy
ones I did I just like jumping up and
trying to touch the top of her head and
we became friends and he would always
say okay well if you can't go out with
me who can you set me up with March and
March are yeah and I was like I I don't
I wouldn't do that to any of my friends
[Music]
this is getting hot this is just out
right I'm gonna [ __ ] your mouth up hot
it is you know a lot of people know you
from Top Chef and your fans know you
obviously a legendary modeling career
and the cookbooks and the memoir but
some people might be surprised that you
actually have a decent little IMDB page
can you tell me about Star Trek
Enterprise because you're on an episode
is called precious cargo they are rabid
fans when do I come up to you like I
know in you from Star Trek not known to
anything else oh yes that's right when
they come up to me it's like a teenage
girl coming up to Justin Bieber it is
the most wonderful feeling in the world
I was only on one episode and then they
made up a whole language for me to speak
you know I'm from a planet called pre
krios prime I'm amazed that I remember
this was at least a decade ago so you
know I would be talking on set and there
are two linguist on set with binders and
so they gently step in very you know
politely and they say you pronounce it
kelabra and it's not kilala it's
called-- way and like nobody's big you
know and they would say know your
language we created this language for
you because it has austro-hungarian
majaa roots and that it was is what it
needs to be and because they publish
this stuff and Trekkies memorize it
and you have you messed up those guys
giving you cars but yeah I'll tell get
incredible fan what mail I mean some of
its kind of creepy but mostly is mellow
it it's really good yeah it's hot mm-hmm
so speaking of hot once said as a child
that wasn't spicy condiments like most
children are with chocolate or candy
what I want to do is hit you with some
spices and maybe you can tell me the
first thing that comes to your mind
other dishes they work in and we'll just
keep them going like that gochujang
gochujang is great it's used in Korean
food I would use it on fish and nothing
like you don't have to use much out
lingam at the West chili
I love Linderman's you do yes how do you
know well you know about lignans is a
Singaporean brand it's wonderful it's
got a lot of sugar in it it's got a lot
of texture in it so it's like a chunky
ketchup beautiful orange color great on
eggs wonderful with into mayonnaise and
slather on sandwiches I love lingams
let's go with a classic Frank's redhot
just your classic buffalo wing sauce I
like it I used a lot of it in college
and I'm nothing bad to say about red-hot
[Music]
sad mahou you're doing pretty good I'm
good I'm good so good you're so good
thank you
we've had football players cry we have
rappers come and take laps around the
place and have to drink themselves silly
look at you look at you why drank a
little milk look at you thank you so
great in Seoul again all right so this
one is mad dog 357 357 thousand Scoville
units used to be our hottest sauce I
usually heard that I'm going to tell you
something and I kind of talk about this
in the encyclopedia the Scoville units
are not really empirically correct
because it's Scoville scale was very
arbitrary and that's why I love that you
said that and it's gonna be hot it's
going to hit you but I love that you
said that because I also think that
marketers take advantage of Scoville
units and they try to pretend like oh
this thing's like a gazillion Scoville
this is a billion scope now like it's
obviously not dude Claire lying about it
let's go go take them out don't make fun
it's fun to say then also it's always in
the thousands so it would that mean you
know right what do you think of Mad Dog
I think it's kind of a dog so I want to
talk to you about being a professional
eater because you and I sort of know the
pitfalls that here I have to eat ten
dangerously spicy chicken wings every
week you have to eat sometimes six to
eight thousand calories in a day we know
what it's like now over indulge me I am
when you go to restaurants do they feel
like they need to just start bringing
Ashley yeah and that sounds like it's a
great thing but you're probably like
oftentimes when I go out I'm trying to
make up for all the food that I've eaten
either at my own kitchen or on Top Chef
so I don't really like to eat that heavy
I just try and take a bite of everything
and then move the stuff on the plate so
I don't hurt anyone's feelings do you do
anything to like soothe your stomach
your digestive tract there apricot hell
yeah before we have to do because I need
all the help I can get saying something
called cranberry Drano which is
something I just invented over years and
years of Top Chef it is pure cranberry
juice
so not sweetens
supervisor powder-like clean and clear
fiber powder or miralax or whatever you
like four ounces of green tea with a
teaspoon of honey sure that is brutal
hot and then ice and the vitamin C
packet no vitamin C pack mm-hmm thank
you very much
you know when you have to eat that much
and you have a full stomach never affect
how you taste the dishes because you
know sometimes if you're like hungry
what's harder is when something is yummy
and you want to keep going on you know
yeah I can't I can't yeah you never
think about that I never thought about
that all right
Padma Blair's Megadeath sauce with
liquid rage it is tradition around here
to put a little extra dab on the last
wing Padme you don't have to if you
don't want to laughs if we don't want to
cool I'll put a drop I wanna be a good
score there she is very deliberate there
it is ready
hmm I think that tonight is enough yeah
powerful may money
so right oh my god that's really hot
it's crazy
of all the animal testicles that you see
in your life which pair do you think has
the best shot of becoming a mainstream
menu item duck testicles doc testicles
not that bad
I didn't even know Ducks had testicles
frankly I don't either about it there's
always that one episode which is like
The Fear Factor episode on Top Chef they
stop doing that now because I now have
an EP credit and I tell them I'm not
gonna March but it's always like I've
eaten so much [ __ ] like kangaroo
alligators make alligator and steak on
the same weight I've had bull penises
well yeah that was like kind of know it
was just had a little piece of an I
didn't like it it's very bad I threw my
dick weird the board it was amazing
30-second plug is all yours we just came
for this camera that camera that camera
let the people know what you have going
on real life okay please please watch
tops test we premiered our fourteenth
season we're in Charleston it's on on
Bravo on Thursday night and then buy my
book
bye love loss and what we ate you can
also get it on audible if you don't like
to read you can just have me in your
ears when you're doing your dishes or
whatever and then if you like food or
even if you don't like when you don't
know anything about food please buy the
Encyclopedia of spices and earth thank
you hey what's going on hot ones fans if
you liked the video maybe meet us
halfway throw us a subscribe if you
didn't like the video don't subscribe I
don't want you I don't want you in the
tent but if you liked the video
subscribe thank you very much I
appreciate you I love you more than a
friend